they say this is the hardest multiple
choice question ever if you choose an
answer to this question at random what
is the chance you will be correct a 25 B
50 c zero percent or D 25 percent
now let's say you think the answer is 25
in that case both answer choices A and D
will be correct but then two answer
choices will be correct which is fifty
percent of the answer choices so it
can't be 25 percent now what if you say
that it is 50 in that case only B is the
correct answer and one out of four
answer choices is only 25 so you say
okay there are no answer choices but
that will be answer Choice C which would
lead once again to 25 percent so you're
right back to where you're started
it's a strange game the only winning
move is not to play